families are starting to move into what
is being called America's first solar
powered town Babcock Ranch is about half
an hour north east of Fort Myers Florida
developers are building nearly 20,000
homes for a projected 50,000 people when
the project is finished the town is
supposed to produce more energy than it
consumes Manuel Bojorquez is on a
construction lift with a unique view of
the massive solar field powering the
community and well good morning good
morning up high is really the best way
to give you a sense of scale here just
take a look at this
more than 300,000 solar panels over 440
acres that's enough to power the town
and even some surrounding areas it's
operated by Florida Power and Light on
land donated by the developer of Babcock
Ranch who believes it will serve as a
model for sustainability so you're gonna
give us a spin let's go and give it a
try right
instead Kitson city of the future people
leave their car in the garage and take
rides in self-driving shuttle buses how
far away are we from being able to do
that I think it's a lot sooner than I
think people actually understand it's
much sooner this autonomous vehicle held
with an app is zero emissions it's
powered by electricity generated from
the Sun just like the street lamps the
buildings and the lights we used for
this interview we want to be the most
sustainable new town in the United
States
Kitson a developer wouldn't want it any
other way
Babcock Ranch has been his passion
project since 2005 we had the advantage
of a green field with a blank sheet of
paper and when you have a blank sheet of
paper like this you really can do it
right from the beginning is it more
expensive to build this way is it more
expensive for the consumers you know
it's not it's not more expensive the
people here pay the exact same amount
that everybody else pays in the Florida
Power & Light Network a hurricane coming
through and ripping apart those panels
what would happen then when hurricane
Ehrlich hit Florida the eye of the storm
came right over the top of Babcock Ranch
not one
panel out of 343,000 panels were
dislodged the town doesn't run on solar
power all the time at night when the Sun
is down it has to draw from the
traditional electrical grid Kitson says
the technology for storing all that
surplus energy the solar cells generate
during the day is still too costly
another problem too many overcast days
clearly if you have number of cloudy
days in a row right it will impact the
efficiency and the available electricity
that comes from the solar field this is
Florida but this is Florida and if you
don't like the weather just wait 10
minutes in right this month Richard and
Robin Kinley became the first residents
to move in the lake next to their house
is named after them lake inle you know
there's nice and clean here and I think
these type of communities are the future
I felt very much like when I bought a
Tesla back in 2013 and I said this is
this definitely gonna make it and I felt
the same way about Babcock Ranch their
first neighbors Donna and James Avik
move in at the end of the month we love
the innovation here we think it's a very
small planet and we want to do our part
to conserve it and if you're wondering a
small three-bedroom house will run you
about one hundred ninety five thousand
dollars a two-story four-bedroom near
the lake it's more like 750 thousand
dollars now 80% of the land that Kitson
originally purchased will not be
developed he sold it to the state of
Florida which turned it into a wildlife
preserve Nora man well thank you
absolutely love that story let's talk
about innovation people are trying to do
something show the environment and find
energy in different ways and we always
think the Sun will come up I know
tomorrow you never have to worry it
doesn't coming if it doesn't it's all
stored there bring it up yourself
they're ready